تيك توك ليس هو التطبيق الصيني الوحيد
الذي اثار الشكوك حول استخدامه في التجسس
تطبيق بندوا المختص في التسوق وضع تحت
المجهر بسبب استخدامه برمجيات مشبوهه
ايجابيه رئيس
الحقيقه القادمه التي كشفها تحقيق للشبكه
حول خطوره تطبيق التسوق خبراء الامن
الرقمي من فنلندا وامريكا واسرائيل فحصوا
التطبيق واجمعوا على انه يستغل تقنيات
تسمح له بتصعيد صلاحياته بدون اذن
المستخدم بندود الذي حذف من متجر جوجل في
شهر مارس الماضي بسبب البرمجيات الخبيثه
التي يحتويها يستطيع التلصص على التطبيقات
الاخرى الموجوده على هاتف المستخدم حتى
اذا ما قام المستخدم بالتخلص من فهو في
الواقع لن يكون قد حذف الا ايقونه التطبيق
خبراء الامن الرقم الذين ساهموا في
التحقيق اكدوا انه يتخفى في الهاتف ويستمر
في رصد المعلومات وارسالها للشركه الخبراء
لم يؤكدوا بعد ما اذا كانت الحكومه
الصينيه تستفيد من المعلومات التي يحصل
عليها بندودو ولكن لدى بكين سطوه على
تطبيقاتها تمكنها من الوصول الى اي نوع من
المعلومات التي تريدها ان لم يكن اليوم
ففي المستقبل
انسنا الماسي العربيه